- Well speaking of intimidation,
you re-posted this video someone made.
It's an impression of you meeting
your daughter's boyfriend.
- Oh, you're my daughter's date?
(beeps)
Oh wow!
Could you excuse me for just one moment?
Yes, thank you sir.
Well,
(beeps)
One thing I can tell you,
is that Tilly should've gone to
(beeps)
because I've always got
a face like a dog's ass.
(audience laughs)
For sure.
(audience claps)
- Oh my God!
How accurate is that?
(audience clapping)
- That is 100% accurate.
- I love that you reposted it.
- Yeah, I'm saying no sometimes.
I mean, listen,
I just want the girls to be looked after
and them to look after each other.
So, you're always anxious about that.
And I did something really bad last week.
Megan started seeing
her ex-boyfriend again
and his name is Byron.
- Yeah.
- And it was okay to begin with,
a little bit wet,
a little bit sort of,
you want a man to date your daughter
and he was just a little bit pathetic.
(audience laughs)
- I love you so much.
(Kelly laughs)
Byron is peeing his pants somewhere.
- I wanna kill that
(beeps)
(audience laughs)
I kid you not.
I found out his telephone number
from our youngest daughter, Tilly.
So, she gave me and said,
"Dad, don't do this."
"No just give me the number.
Nothings wrong,
I need his number on my phone."
So, I waited to find out when
they're having dinner together
and I FaceTimed him.
(audience gasps)
- Did your daughter kill you?
- Well, he sort of answered the phone.
This thing was shaking,
I said, "Byron, it's me, not
your future father-in-law
you little"
(beeps)
- Oh my God!
Did your daughter kill you?
- And Megan leant over him
and pushed and cut me off,
which was so rude.
I was just in a middle of having a...
- She's rude?
(Kelly laughs)
Your perspective,
it's a beautiful thing.
- So yeah, it's hard, right?
- Oh.
- It's hard.
- And you know dudes,
so, you're like,
"Nope."
- Yeah, and also you just want the best,
but then, 22 is just like,
no, just wait a little bit longer but...
- Yeah, I say 30 is a good age to start.